here's what it is if you look at the
earth and you look at a person or
anything giving birth it's much the same
like I think people are very married to
keeping the mammalian garden-party alive
you know like we have to save the
resources and all this stuff and it's
true we want to keep a beautiful healthy
planet that's sustainable for future
generations and for all of us
but at the same time all this is
happening for a reason and we all have a
role to play in this and it's not by
mistake
okay so through every birth there is you
know the stretching of organs the
shedding of blood screaming and it's
like the the if you if you didn't if
you've never seen a birth before and you
turned a corner and you saw it you would
lose your mind yeah you think you have a
serious medical emergency but if you
have your wits about you and you know
what's going down you're like oh this is
how new life comes into existence this
is how it's always been and it happens
on every level so the chicken egg has to
crack in order for the for the chick to
emerge the placenta has to be torn and
shed and torn asunder and that's exactly
what's happening in the earth you know
the earth is like a giant egg and we are
breaking the shell and you know the
placenta is opening and new
consciousness is emerging and all of us
are playing our role in that mm-hmm it's
like this divine ballet beautiful
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Sathyan we
are on site in the beautiful Topanga
California we are now going to be
talking about conscious evolution we
have Umberto Braga joining us on the
show hey all thanks for having me I'm so
pumped for this conversation with Berto
thanks for coming on yeah
we're gonna rock this for those who
don't know Umberto's background he's a
writer an artist an entrepreneur focused
on conscious evolution healing awakening
and breeding creative solutions to
uplift humanity and you can find the
links in the bio below to his work all
right
I'm paired so let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions to
ask our guests what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world yeah so I
think the first thing that people go to
when we think about the world is just
how crazy things are and how dark it is
and there is that but I really see it as
a catalyst for awakening that's what's
happening it's like a pressure cooker
that's making people forced to look at
their own [ __ ] to wake up like you have
to there's no way and I you know while
there's a lot of pessimism I'm actually
really optimistic like what I feel
because never before in history have we
had so many people looking into
self-work going deeper into things and
at a more you know exponential pace with
the internet a lot more people have
access to healing possibilities
resources and so that to me signifies
that you know all this stuff whether
it's you know the political stuff or
industrial civilization that's depleting
entire ecosystems like there's a reason
why this is happening and I think from a
broader perspective when you pull away
from the subjective you know the desire
to save the trees and the bees and the
whales and the snails and all that stuff
you have to look back at the greater
intelligence and say why is this
happening well I think the only
consistent the only constant through all
of evolution is the evolution of
consciousness like its growth I mean
from dirt to single-celled organisms you
know finish to like it the earth wants
consciousness to evolve that's the only
constant so all this craziness that's
going on is meant to advance that
project of being that's really what it's
all about and so I'm really excited
because I think we have a lot of great
potential opening to us there's a lot of
dangers too we have to watch out there
but you know I think that there's a
divine intelligence working through
everything so I think that there's a
fair amount of Providence yeah it's it's
interesting that you call it a pressure
cooker I like that as well that there's
there's now so many pressures being put
on us to evolve our own consciousness
and there's so many pockets of
consciousness uplifting that's currently
happening in all different types of
modalities you listed self work as this
that's such a critical one and it's if
not the most critical one and there's so
many ways to do self work and then
that's kind of like all these different
modalities are opening up which is
awesome and I like how you also put it
in the scale of like deep time that ever
since the beginning of life on this rock
that it's just been going towards
complexity evolving towards complexity
and evolving towards propagating more
consciousness for consciousness to have
more meaning more creativity for more
connection more expression all those
things yes yes for to be able to
understand source better and yeah I
wanna I want to ask you about that I
don't ask you about that next I want to
ask you a question along the way which
is um what would you say is a main
principle for us to embody to really
push the envelope of our own conscious
evolution I mean that's it's a hard
question to answer because everyone's
path is so different you know like when
you say us that people are so vastly
different in their levels of being that
it's hard to give a one size fits all
very I want to do I mean if I had to
choose one thing I think it would just
like learning to be yeah just be yeah
can you I mean I there's a person who I
really loves work his name is Phillip
Sheppard yeah we had a mantra we listen
no no I love Phillip and he has a really
great way of talking about embodiment
and you know how with yourself can you
be yeah and how much of the world can
you take in not just with your your eyes
and your ears and your thoughts which
are constantly either projecting it in
the future or comparing from the past
but just being the breath yeah being
present and then from that point then
when you're interacting with other
people you're not taking their you know
anything that's offensive from them
you're not taking it personally because
you see it that it's disproportionate to
the moment it's from their projections
from their wounding and you find a
greater expansive place of being to hold
the world and you know it's not you're
not so against it all you know and I've
learned that from my own past I had a
really rough childhood so this isn't
just me living in Topanga
in Los Angeles some bougie whatever like
it's taken me a long time to get here
through a lot of horrible stuff hmm and
that's been one of the biggest races for
me is being able to just embody that
being and just be with my experience and
other people's and to hold it yeah
that's a that's a critical point of self
work is to learn how to just be and that
is also actually really conducive to our
own divine communion with source the
more that we just be the more we can tap
into things that are a little bit more
ethereal than just this using language
and sociability which is we're usually
hyper conditioned to do in every moment
of time that we had a spare moment of
time that we have
you know walk us through that journey
though and some of the things as much as
you'd like to share yeah yeah well I
mean just to give you that quick I'd
want to go to this like huge Oprah
Winfrey moment like ya know so I was my
mom was born deaf and my father was from
Brazil he was very abusive to her my mom
had to take me away when I was three and
she had a very traumatic childhood she
passed that childhood onto me with a lot
of abuse in many different ways so I
grew up with complex post-traumatic
stress disorder which I didn't know
about until like three years ago I'd say
so what wound up happening is that I've
just been going through this process of
stripping away the layers of armor and
conditioning and my process has kind of
looked like ever since I was young I
knew that there was something wrong with
the world and I always had questions you
know even though I was little like I
would look up at the stars and it's not
even just like Oh what are those but
it's like this feeling like there's
something looking back at me mm-hm and
there's something out there there's more
what is it and I could feel like this
this pull and you know I think one of
the best one of the best symbolisms for
my childhood is I used to have this this
hobby of breaking open rocks like just
digging up rocks plain-looking rocks and
looking inside for the crystals mm-hmm
and that's kind of what I do with my
life I smash things open to look for the
treasure inside that's what I've been
doing ever since and you know and mostly
the thing I've been smashing is myself
mm-hmm and you know obviously that's
been that's opened up a lot of doors
because then you get in I got into
spirituality psychedelics which blast
open a lot of doors then you know
getting deeper in esotericism like
kerchief Rabia Hermeticism Gnosticism
and all that and going much much deeper
and yeah while still being inundated by
the New Age scene here in Los Angeles
which is very distorted spirituality
and so trying to find some equilibrium
and compassion through all that and not
letting the ego come in like you guys
don't know what you're talking about but
trying to understand like okay this is
where they're at everyone awakens in
their own time it's part of the process
and you have to onto that and meet them
where they're at instead of saying you
need to get up here ya understand you
know so that through the process of
going through all that stuff I got
deeper into the emotional work when I
started reading about Psychopaths and
power mmm
like I'm just studying about psychology
and like okay why are the people in
power doing this oh they're Psychopaths
okay the psychopathy has taken over
corporations and banking and it's all
insane but then in the process of
reading about psychopathy I learned
about things like narcissistic wounding
yeah and like childhood wounding and
reading in every page I'm like [ __ ] this
is me and just realizing that there was
so much in myself that needed to be
taken care of and then seeing in
everyone else me too yeah and just like
who there's so much that needs to be
loved and so much I needs to be brought
to light yeah and that's and I realized
that even through the process of you
know I've been abducted by
extraterrestrials along the way like
that's a whole nother thing
damn and realizing through studying a
lot of work up in the extraterrestrial
phenomenon that all of it comes down to
clearing out your own stuff and healing
it like yeah there's there's the
knowledge aspect but if unless you clear
this out you're always going to be a
vector for attack yes okay so there's a
couple aspects to the journey the first
one is that it's it's interesting that
you have the same sort of story arc that
a lot of other people that we sit down
with half that are really deeply aware
of their conscious evolution which is
that they found their greatest treasures
on the other side of their traumas and
that they really had to go through that
process of deep serious reflection
looking in the mirror about themselves
and understanding themselves who they
are who their parents were how they
became who they were today and then
doing that process of healing and
integrating and feeling divine and
finding out what is my purpose here what
is my role and pursuing that with great
vigor
and then it's also interesting that the
people that you were listing that you
were that you are studying and you know
girge if there's just so much of this
that's now made more commonly available
with the democratization of information
technology that we can just more so
access it access the signal more easily
but there's also a lot of noise we were
giving this example of the some
sometimes we look at New Age spiritual
things and we're like okay like I guess
there's different ways you know that I
guess yeah yeah and and it's and you got
a you know like you said you're very
careful with not you know with not
saying that this is the right way and
whatnot at the same time that you know
that there are and you've seen it in
yourself and you now see it in other
people but you see how people awaken you
see their processes you see there's a
deep psychopathy that exists in social
in certain people and how it can
actually be healed and we can live with
a more loving more peaceful healed
society and make it easier for children
who are born into the world to access
their own divine communion and
actualization and bringing their gifts
forward but that requires us to do this
long process of our own self work as
well as building that social fabric that
we all know that is possible yeah yeah
okay let's do um more on the connection
to source what has been your connection
with all that is my connection to all
that is that's a big question
mm-hmm I guess I've always felt like
there's
a force guiding me and and for a long
time I used to think like is this like
is this ego to think that I'm special or
something like that but no I feel like
we all have for people who I think
there's some people who come here with a
mission let's put it that way all right
they call them you know Wanderers or
star seeds or whatever you want to call
them and I think that for myself my
relationship has always been that I have
a purpose and as I started getting into
astrology and human design in numerology
then things started popping up like oh
it's it that's what it says in my chart
and like it's there there there there
there and I started to piece the the
puzzle together a little bit by a little
bit and my relationship has been one
primarily of trust for the most part and
that's been a big lesson because it's
trust now before I used to be rage I
used to be so pissed off and because of
all the trauma and all the injustice is
in the world and like you know I always
thought of myself as okay we're part of
God sure yeah and love enlighten yada
yada yada but that's what we that's what
we come from that's what we'll return to
write because objectivity embraces all
things
it holds all things with love and grace
and so that's fine but I'm here in the
subjective process and I'm [ __ ] pissed
off like I have all this childhood rage
and all these things are happening
everyone's asleep
so for a long time I was very vitalic to
people and very like you know light
things on fire conversationally like if
you don't see the truth I'm gonna break
down a shed of your paradigm [ __ ] you
you're getting the heavy truth right now
end of story or get the [ __ ] out that's
the way I was and I saw that as like
being the righteous sort of truth and I
think in some circuits circumstances
like that energy is very helpful mmm but
doing it surgically and with tact yes
and
compassion that's critical that's the
that's the part that I've kind of
integrated into it skillfully
planting the seeds right yeah and
watering them and having the other
person go home and water them right here
and so I feel like you know what's
interesting I for a long time I had this
this pressure and this goes back to the
trust thing with the divine like I had
this pressure like oh my god we're
running out of time and resources and
what's you manatee gonna do and I
realized you know I can't save the world
and there's a part of me that would
really love to you know I think we all
want to on some level because we care so
much you know but there's a certain
amount of like okay this is all part of
an unfolding process through a wisdom
that's greater than ours yeah that we
can ever fathom and we have to trust the
process and trust ourselves as long as
we're aligned with you know divine
purpose and awakening and healing and
all those things that align us with
truth yes then the rest will unfold as
it should
yes yes so the more that we consciously
evolve ourselves and then have that
divine force that's channeling through
us to be a conscious creator on in the
world and we surrender to that process
and we let that force drive us that
force is greater than ourselves the more
it feels like we are actually in a
communion and not ego driven I want to
ask a question this has been one of my
favorite wants to recently ask but how
do you decide during your process of
conscious evolution when you have like
this this option you know you're gonna
write or you're gonna work on your art
for four hours or you're gonna go on a
hike for four hours how do you know
which one is the right choice for you
where do you like feel that intuition
that type of stuff how do you know how
you're being guided by full yeah I just
go with what I feel I just and where do
you feel it I you know what it is it's
like it's a feeling of Epiphany
interesting you know I mean like I I
don't try to force things like if I'm
gonna work obviously I'm gonna sit down
and put the time into it but not because
like I feel like oh god I have to do
this yeah because you know what to all
this it's a day job yeah but that's like
I'm talking for the passion like it
comes in emerges from me like I have a
passion for writing I have a passion for
creating and touching others yeah and
seeing them like ignite and to come and
live and and enlightened and I love that
and it makes me just overwhelmed but you
know I can go and hike anytime you know
so if yeah if I've been letting my ass
pancake on a seat all day and like well
I could go in a hike if I'm still in the
flow it's like okay I'll get up and I'll
do a little bit of yoga chi gong and
I'll get into my body for a little bit
and walk around but you know I'm gonna
stay here and stay in the zone I'm gonna
embrace that okay and then how about
does it feel like everything that's
unfolding this grand creation that's
unfolding does it feel like it's a big
artistic expression of God or source
does it feel like we're all different
like paint strokes on the canvas or
instruments that are being played in the
symphony yeah I think that's one way to
look at it I think you can look at it
from the artistic perspective you can
look at it from you know a chemist
perspective like we're all different
chemical elements coalescing and some of
us are catalysts some of us are bases
you know and it's you can look at from
different analogies yeah and really what
it is is here's what it is if you look
at the earth and you look at a person or
anything giving birth it's much the same
like I think people are very married to
keeping the mammalian garden-party alive
you know like we have to save the
resources and all this stuff and it's
true we want to keep a beautiful healthy
planet that's sustainable for future
generations and for all of us but at the
same time all this is happening for a
reason and we all have a role to play in
this
and it's not by mistake okay
so through every birth there is you know
the stretching of organs the shedding of
blood screaming and it's like the the if
you if you didn't if you've never seen
it birth before and you turned a corner
and you saw it you would lose your mind
yeah you think you have a serious
medical emergency but if you have your
wits about you and you know what's going
down you're like oh this is how new life
comes into existence this is how it's
always been and it happens on every
level so the chicken egg has to crack in
order for the for the chick to emerge
the placenta has to be torn and shed and
torn asunder and that's exactly what's
happening in the earth you know the
earth is like a giant egg and we are
breaking the shell and you know the
placenta is opening and new
consciousness is emerging and all of us
are playing our role in that mm-hmm it's
like this divine ballet beautiful yeah
yeah now I love the analogies the
chemistry one the the egg that's
cracking open the chick emerging now you
know I think another good question here
that we discussed quite a bit is that
there seem to be forces that are at play
that are in the sense you've you've
written about this the matrix control
system it seems as though there is evil
and evil serves its purpose in many ways
what do you how do you see good and evil
and how do you see malevolent forces at
play on what looks like and feels like a
chess board or a game board that is
planet earth and trying to maybe take
control of that chick that's cracking
from the egg yeah so at its core like if
you really boil it down to like what is
good and evil I would say that good is
truth and freedom mm-hmm evil is
deception and control trying to control
others yeah and it's really comes down
to objectivity versus subjectivity like
embracing the divine and what is
or trying to control everything and
trying to bend it to your will which is
essentially trying to get into a
staredown contest with the universe like
you're not gonna win so objectivity
always wins so get on the right side of
life get on the side of objectivity
because the subject of the evil part is
gonna be a losing game no matter what
mm-hmm
that's just the end of story and then
how do you how do you see what's at play
on the as like this this board game
that's on the planet do you do you feel
as though there are you know off off
world forces that are coming at play
through us as channels 100% okay and
then tell us about your relationship and
with yeah so I've seen UFOs consistently
since I was a kid and your abduction as
well so it teaches about that too yes
yes so I was abducted when I was 28 27
and I woke up in a dream and I was
someplace I'm never going to walk you
through the whole story I'll give you
the little short rundown but I was
walking through this mental asylum and I
was just touching this bathroom curtain
and I pushed open and there was this
black spider that came down and bit my
left arm but I felt it on my right arm
so I knew I was sleeping like oh I don't
want to be here let me wake up and I
forced myself to wake up and when I woke
up I was laying down on a table and
there was just this ambient lighting I
didn't know where I was and have you
ever been on the ride called the
Gravitron circus were like you up
against the world
gravity and I was trying to look around
and see what's happening and I couldn't
move my neck so I had to do a bicep curl
those are crazy I forgot what I think
there's a an actual medical terminology
for it when you're you're you're
physically like you said that the like a
circus grab it's wrong when you're just
being put like you keep commanding
yourself to want to move but you can't
and you're in a dream state and it's
really it kind of like hurts your spirit
because you're like I have completely
lost physical motor control yeah yeah
which is terrifying yeah
and yeah I think there's there's one
thing called sleep paralysis where you
know that so you don't you know when you
having a bad dream you don't run out of
your bed and whack up against the wall
but this is something different and I
did a bicep curl and I put my hand in
with my head and I forced my head up and
when I did there were two gray
extraterrestrials that came out of the
darkness and I just remember thinking
holy [ __ ] it's happening to me
this is real like I knew it was real but
you don't know how real it is until like
you have that like heaving sickness in
your stomach of oh my god they're right
there and I remembered at that moment
Karla Turner who is this famous UFO gist
who was saying that one of the greatest
tools that a person has during the point
of abduction is anger like for food use
your anger that's willpower because this
really it's about conscious from
willpower and focus and anger is
fantastic at that so what I did is I
just thought like you [ __ ] abducted
me like you kidnapped me and how dare
you know what I mean and I just got so
livid that I just fought to get up as
hard as I could and I started you know
pushing myself up towards them and then
the gravity just increased so hard that
it slammed me back on the table and then
another gray came right over my head by
this close like a foot away from me and
big almond black eyes and I just started
falling asleep and I couldn't stay awake
but in my head I was like I'm still here
you can't like you can do whatever you
like you're doing whatever you can but
I'm still here you're never gonna touch
me I want to get out of here I want to
wake up now and I woke up and it was
like 3:00 something in the morning and
at the time I like looked outside and
there's nothing around okay I went back
to bed and mind you at the time I was in
body work school so I had no nails right
or anything like that and I was fully
clothed nothing sharper on the bed but
when I woke up to get dressed
I had claw marks on my body and I had a
triangular cut out of the back bernhard
gunther who's my good friend i showed
him this - and he's like holy god like
there was no way like it was like animal
claw marks and there's a puncture wound
right here dead center so yes there are
malevolent forces out there all that to
say there are many malevolent forces out
there but just like the way we feed on
chickens
you know vegetables and like we
manipulate them for our life feeds on
light life yeah yeah and if you have
weak points of your spiritual
fragmentation you open up you are a vet
director yeah so yeah there are
definitely dark forces out there but
ultimately they are just opportunities
to awaken right like they're just
challenges in front of us like okay
you're faced with an obstacle how are
you gonna shift your blueprint your
beliefs your abilities and integrate
that into your life to get around it you
want I mean to use it to your advantage
because you can use those things to
either like anchor you down like oh this
is so hard and there's so much
oppression in the world or you can use
it to your advantage and use it as fuel
like you the anger thing you know like I
will not let this get me down I'm gonna
be better than this I'm gonna be bigger
than this I have a greater purpose than
this that sort of thing you know yes yes
I want I want to become more open and
have society become more open to hearing
stories involving extraterrestrials and
what what can occur from abductions what
what is actually going on in this
process of the physical body going
anywhere is it just the spirit that's
going somewhere what what is what are
these processes like what are what are
the entities that are attempting to do
with that all this all these questions
and so I would just like to open up more
dialogue around what is in many ways
it's it's esoteric and it's also just
like it's against the normal path of
thinking like we're not talking about
these things on mainstream media so what
about the relationship between what's
unfolding with creation and what role
freewill plays in that versus
determinism so I think that when most
people think of free will they
they don't understand that everything
exists in relationship okay nothing
exists in a vacuum
hmm so therefore what is free will you
know what I mean because if you exist
with something else there's always that
relationship so that's a constraint on
your will whether it's you know gravity
or you know I mean like down to the
molecular level there's always something
if you look at even quantum physics like
every molecule affects the other so I
think that when it comes to free will
the best we can do is bypass certain
universal laws you know you look at
astrology for example right and these
are cosmic forces and those shoes that
is one example there's many of them
there are many cosmic forces that are at
play and whether or not we're conscious
of them dictates whether or not you we
fall under their control or we can
bypass them whether it's from other
people you know like if there's a
beautiful woman coming on to you and yet
you have a deadline on a project and
this woman is trying to seduce you but
you're aware of like oh you know what
this is the matrix coming at me because
they don't want me to finish this
project I'm going to step aside for a
moment and just let that be because I
this is more important and there's no
future here even though my lower
impulses want me to pursue this yeah
that's one of those things like the
matrix works through other people and
free will only comes when we are
conscious of the way that those forces
work through us interesting because we
can bypass those forces and play with it
it's the unseen forces that really
dictate how much free will we have two
less spiritually fragmented we are the
more free will we have and the more
spiritually fragmented we are the less
free will
we have correct the more we're kind of
driven around like puppets yeah yeah
interesting and then is the what would
you say I like the most common you were
giving this example of this there's a
sexual proclivity that's maybe one of
these most common matrix control forces
that come in to try and vector people
off of spiritual awakening or
being service to others yeah so what
what are these other vectors that you
think are most relatable that you feel I
think that this is the search for
significance for people like and people
say ego but I would say the search for
personal significance let you look at
Instagram and social media just in
general nowadays and everyone wants to
be seen mm-hmm and it's all for
superficial reasons instead of deep
meaningful contributions yeah that would
equate to because people want to feel
connection but it's very Hollow and so
it's the pitfall of taking these
inherent needs which we all have we all
have you know human needs but distorting
them and so there's the lust there's the
connection there's the significance
there's the vanity as well so there's a
lot of aspects to ego that we have to
look out for even the connection to God
can be a trap itself like I want if I
want to be spiritual you know what I
mean
yeah and people try to shoot right up
the top of the mountain and they you
know even they take a lot of
psychedelics and I think that that's
gonna make them more conscious but they
don't have the foundation underneath so
it's like sticking a bottle rocket up
your butt and then shooting up to the
sky and you hang out there for a second
but then you have to come crashing down
eventually and ultimately I think what
it comes down to is just doing the
fundamental work and then you will you
know build the proper foundation and all
those things will naturally emerge like
if you love yourself then loving others
will emerge if you see the beauty in all
things and you will see your own beauty
yeah you know it's it's that sort of mmm
that is that's how you get past the
pitfalls so there's a lot of nuances
lots of little things in there yeah I
write about all of these I try to attack
them one at a time just trying to clear
out the the debris from it because
there's a lot of stuff even down to like
having kids you know and like my role as
a parent and yeah needing love from
other people it's it's multifaceted yeah
this idea of like I want spiritual
awakening in five minutes but I took
like over ten years to learn language
right let's be real
there's gonna be a forever journey to
spiritual awakening absolutely now do
you feel like we're all when we all come
into the world did we do you feel like
we came in a spirit to meet the body and
then we came in with a mission and that
earth is like our school that we're here
achieving that mission is that kind of
how you view it or how do you view it
I think everyone comes in with a
different mission some people like
there's there's esoteric literature
about how not everyone has a soul yeah
some people are recently incarnated from
the animal realm right where people are
more defined by the herd and by their
lower impulses you know you see people
like that they cling to society and
government and authoritarian structures
and religion because they need to be
part of this collective and that's how
they identify themselves with these you
know external reference points there's
other people who can see through that
and they have an inner magnetic Center
that's now this is who I am
this is truth this is what's real not
that damn this is all fleeting so not
everyone is the same not everyone comes
into this world with the same construct
and by the way not everyone goes to the
same place afterwards either mm-hmm so
that's a whole other conversation so
yeah I think ultimately yes spirit or
soul meets the flesh here to learn
lessons I also feel that some people
come here when they are more advanced to
fulfill a purpose and fulfill a role and
there's this inner knowing and the
matrix especially goes after people with
that because they want to shut them down
mmm because if they don't want them to
awaken to awaken and awaken others
because that you know that ruins the
game then they lose their food source to
feed on people energetically so they
need to keep everything down and if
anyone pops up and starts to awakening
like Oh put the forces on him you know
it's like neo in the matrix when the
woman in red walks by yeah
you know you have to they try to
distract you yes and then you gave this
example of we of a spear potentially
incarnated from the animal realm from
the previous life and that having maybe
more of a tendency to need a government
or a religion or something
but then there's also this example of
what well what happens you know
post-death and you we're gonna walk us
down that tell us about your thoughts
regarding that sure so I think that
people with more advanced Souls go
you know onward to the higher densities
which is again another big topic of you
know consciousness and how it evolves
using a certain density model but I
think that if you don't have a magnetic
center to your soul if you haven't done
self work if you are completely or
primarily identified with external
constructs then when you die that's all
gone and then so are you you returned
back to the spirit pool of prime
consciousness they're you know conscious
matter of just plain spirit like
everything has a spirit the grass has
the spirit that cat has the spirit you
know everything has a spirit but it
doesn't have a magnetic soul that's
unified so different people you know
they can either just go back to that
spirit pool and return back to the
primordial essence of what is or if they
are a soul that's forming then they can
slowly congeal their identity and their
inner knowing or they can go back and
you know choose to reincarnate somewhere
else with the mission there's a lot of
different possibilities okay and then
what's the ultimate teleology of the
species what's the purpose of the human
experiment is it that we are part of
this divine creation and that we are
having to figure out how to level up
consciousness meanwhile there is that
evil that's purposely there to make it
more difficult along the way
and that this is part of source having a
beautiful expression of itself in us
communing with it is that kind of like
this ultimate there's a for meaning and
for creativity to get expressed more in
the world yeah I think that I mean
that's a beautiful way to put it first
of all I definitely think that's part of
it and I think another part of it is
just learning to ultimately when it
comes to the greater purpose of things
we're here too
evolved consciousness like we said but
it's in a specific way we have
technology like the internet that's
coming through
we're basically learning to connect with
each other but we can go two ways we can
go one technologically which is
artificial which serves a purpose but we
also have the organic way which we have
clairvoyance and psychic ability clear
cognizance and inner gnosis which a lot
of esoteric esoteric teachings write
about which is you know awakening the
inner connection and I've had this
before with lucid dreaming where I've
been I've witnessed things that happened
around the world I'd call my friend the
next day and say hey I dream about you
and this is what happened in the
Dreaming they said oh my gosh that
actually happened to me last night yeah
and so it's those sort of things where
we don't need technology there's an
organic technology within us yes and we
can awaken that not just to connect but
also to heal ourselves yes and to just
become more you know again connected and
with ourselves with the world with
others and yeah it's just remembering
and learning what we can be and who we
truly are mm-hmm yeah I love the
biological inherent intelligence that's
right here and that when we externalize
the the divine communion two of these
appendages and technologies that then it
makes civilization less stable and
ushers potentially in collapse dynamics
versus coming from within it's easier to
find that love that peace that harmony
with nature I wanna I want I want you to
talk about this because we're we're also
a little bit you have um guide true is
coming out in the fall of this year and
I would love for you to teach about what
is guide true and let's talk about it
sure so guide true first of all it's
going to be an online wellness search
platform that basically takes people
through a personal assessment that
allows them to chart their progress in
terms of their wellness and also custom
matches them with practitioner
of all types for whatever they need and
their content and it's so it serves both
are the members and the practitioners as
well so I don't know if you've ever
tried to get like to find a therapist
it's like dating it's really hard you
spend so much time and money and energy
and it's just it becomes so daunting for
a lot of people that they just say
forget it I'm just gonna you know pop
open a beer or smoke something and they
don't even go with it because it's just
too much work well guide true is going
to be a way for people to connect with
the resources they need for free and
they're gonna be able to get them on
their own terms
so they're gonna be audio-visual written
resources they're gonna be able to
connect for free with the practitioners
and I think it's a great way for people
who are practitioners to be seen by the
right people as well sincere people and
they're gonna be able to get passive
income from their content on the
platform yeah and they're gonna be able
to get the practitioner or the the
members information to so it cuts down
on the intake process so it's a way to
expedite healing on every level for
whatever your level may need yeah that's
huge that's huge it's it's also the
facilitation of conscious evolution
through a platform that is itself
consciously evolved in doing things with
the deeper ethos that is not
profiteering driven but that is driven
by being at service though there's this
massive there's a couple other ones out
that are really interesting wisdom we
had boys going on our show we really
like his platform or if I 1000 people
are using right now it's an Israeli
company they did match matching people
based on being able to learn from others
wisdoms so if somebody has went through
something that you're currently going
through that you'll get matched in to
talking to them about it it's been stuff
like that there's so much potential for
died true and for all these other ones
that are popping up because they
basically are going to be the the the
it's in a sense it's like the the tinder
of of spiritual connecting towards
towards our conscious evolution
half just yeah just be able to find out
where where where can I go next who can
I talk to next how can I get the
resources I need to do that conscious
evolution process also Joyce Hart's
another really interesting one he's
doing I am and we are which is Lin
gamifying know thyself in the North Star
path and so it's also about that
conscious evolution process you know
these are good partners though we could
let's explore let's see what we can do
about that I love it
love it what about and I'm excited to
promote it to the links going to be in
the bio for that everyone so do check
that out now do you feel like we're in a
simulation
I think perception is a simulation
ultimately yeah we are but that doesn't
mean it's necessarily false mmm I think
there's a lot of truth to be found in
that as well it's just interpretation
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world the most beautiful
thing in the world I it's a tie it's a
toss-up either
breakthroughs no that's what it is Britt
I just tied it together
it's breakthroughs and epiphanies in
healing ooh like it's great when a
person hits that point where it's just
like it unlocks for them yes and like oh
my god and it all falls together like
witnessing that being in that space
where everything simultaneously crumbles
and then like the possibilities open up
at the same time yes and this overflow
of just emotion and freedom and sorrow
and excitement at the same time it's
yeah it's like a it's like a soul orgasm
it is yeah it's like the it's like
everything collapsing but celebrating at
the same time yeah it's beautiful
breakthroughs and epiphanies in healing
I believe that's the first time we've
had that and I love soul orgasm soul
gasm soul gasm yeah you know it's
interesting because the soil gassim
happens through those breakthroughs in
epiphanies and healing it also happens
when you get like a breakthrough an
epiphany in
in conscious evolution through the
connection of like maybe like disparate
ideas that you've recently picked one up
and you realized holy [ __ ] no that adds
a whole new aspect to my worldview now I
get a big puzzle piece now and like
those are also just soul gas rooms like
yeah I love that so it works I love that
do you feel like we need to cover
anything else do you feel good I feel
pretty good I feel great thanks for
having me out here this ability I wanna
do this again
this is I hope people you know reach out
and let's talk more about this we need
to yes
yeah about conscious evolution in
general reach out to umberto also for
guy true as well reach out to umberto
check out the links in the bio below
thank you very much my pleasure on the
show thank you so much that's great yeah
I love it and I love how we finally made
this first in person and the interview
happened I'm so pumped for further
co-creating absolutely let's do this
everyone have more conversation to your
friends families stalkers people online
on social media about conscious
evolution about the topics that we
talked about today let's make it more
common to hear people around the world
talking about this and learning and
growing individually and together also
check out the links in the bio below
again to Umberto's work and also support
the artists entrepreneurs the
organizations the community leaders in
your area support them help them grow
support simulation our links are in the
bio below to our patreon paypal
cryptocurrency links support us help us
grow and also
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much
thanks for tuning in and we will see you
soon peace it's a rat brother as amazing
fantastic yeah so much super like
multifaceted
[Music]